جوان بونبيرج هي صاحبة عمل مزدحمة
ومؤلفة
في أواخر الأربعينيات من عمرها ، بدأت تنسى
أشياء مثل
المكان الذي تركت فيه مفاتيحها أو هاتفها بصراحة ،
أحيانًا ما يقود جسدك فقط
ولكن نسيان أسماء الأشخاص أو المكان
الذي تضع فيه شيئًا أمرًا طبيعيًا تمامًا مع
تقدمنا في ال
ن.  أخبار لعقل سليم ،
لن تزداد سوءًا مع تقدمك في السن ،
إليك ما يحدث في قدرتنا على
معالجة المعلومات ، ببساطة تصبح أبطأ
كيف نشفر ونتعلم معلومات جديدة
أبطأ
أدمغتنا تتقلص مع تقدمنا في العمر ولكن ال
علومات التي تحاول تذ
رها  لم تضيع ، يستغرق الأمر وقتًا أطول
لتسميته ، يصبح الدماغ في منتصف العمر أكثر
تشتتًا ،
لذا يصعب علينا التركيز على
ضبط المعلومات غير ذات الصلة ،
لذا مثل تنظيم جوان ، اجعل القوائم
تنظر في جدولك
الزمني وتضع أشياء مثل مفاتيحك  في
مكان مخصص ، فإن
البقاء نشيطًا بدنيًا ونشطًا عقليًا
والمشاركة في التعلم المستمر
يساعد الدماغ على تطوير
مسارات جديدة وتصبح
المسارات الحالية أكثر هشاشة
أكثر وضوحا
والمعلومات تنتقل عبر تلك المسارات
بشكل أسرع قليلاً
وأخيراً لا تنسَ حس الفكاهة لديك ،
أفضل استخدام طاقتي
للضحك بدلاً من
التنهد في الدقيقة الصحية اليوم أنا هولي فيرفر